so I've been thinking about the
difference between resume virtues and
the eulogy virtues the resume virtues
are the ones you put on your resume
which are the skills you bring to the
marketplace the eulogy virtues are the
ones that can mention the eulogy which
are deeper who are you are in your depth
what is the nature of your relationships
are you bold loving dependable
consistency and most of us including me
would say that the eulogy virtues are
more important in the virtues but at
least my case are they the ones that I
think about the most and the answer is
no so I've been thinking about that
problem and a thinker who's helped me
think about it was a guy named Joseph
soloveitchik who's a rabbi he wrote a
book a little only man of faith in 1965
soloveitchik said there are two sides of
our natures when she called Adam one and
Adam - Adam one is the worldly ambitious
external side of our nature he wants to
build create create companies create
innovation Adam - is the humble side of
our nature Adam - not only to do good
but to be good to live in a way
internally that honors God creation and
our possibilities Adam one wants to
conquer the world
Adam two wants to hear a calling in a
bay the world Adam one savors
accomplishment
Adam - savers in a consistency and
strength Adam one asks how things work
Adam - asks why we're here
Adam ones motto is success Adam two's
motto is love Redemption and return and
soloveitchik argued that these two sides
of our nature are at war with each other
where you're live in perpetual self
confrontation between the external
success and the internal value and the
tricky thing I'd say about these two
sides of our nature is they work by
different logics the external logic is
an economic logic input leads to output
risk leads to reward the internal side
of our nature is immoral logic and often
an inverse logic you have to give to
receive you have to disinterred
something outside yourself to gain
strength though then in yourself you
have to conquer the desire to get with
you
in order to fulfill yourself you have to
forget yourself in order to find
yourself you have to lose yourself we
happen to live in a society that favors
atom one and often neglects atom two and
the problem is that turns you into a
shrewd animal who treats life as a game
and you become a cold calculating
creature who slips into a sort of
mediocrity where you realize you there's
a difference between your desire itself
in your actual self you're not earning
the sort of eulogy you want you hope
someone will give to you you don't have
the depth of conviction you don't have
an emotional sonorous nosov commitment
to tasks that would take more than a
lifetime to commit I was reminded of a
common response through history of how
you build a Sodom atom - how you build a
depth of character through history
people have gone back into their own
pasts sometimes for precious time in
their life to their childhood and often
the mind gravitates in the past to a
moment of shame some sim committed some
act of selfishness an act of omission of
shallowness the sin of anger the sin of
self-pity trying to be a people pleaser
a lack of courage atom one is built by a
building on your strengths atom 2 is
built by fighting your weaknesses you go
into yourself you find the sin which
you've committed over and again through
your life your signature sin out of
what's the others emerge and you fight
that sin and you wrestle with that sin
and out of that wrestling that's
suffering then a depth of character is
constructed and we're often not taught
to recognize the sin in ourselves and
now we're not taught in this culture how
to wrestle with it how to confront it
and how to combat it we live in a
culture with an atom one mentality where
we're inarticulate about Adam to finally
Reinhold Niebuhr summed up the
confrontation the fully lived Adam 1 and
Adam to life this way
nothing that is worth doing can be
achieved in our lifetime therefore we
must be saved by hope nothing which is
true
beautiful or good makes complete sense
in any immediate context of history
therefore we must be saved by faith
nothing we do however virtuous and be
accomplished alone therefore we must be
saved by love no virtuous act is quite
as virtuous from the standpoint of our
friend or foe as from our own standpoint
therefore we must be saved by that final
form of love which is forgiveness thanks
[Applause]